the first and most obvious of all of the
pricing strategies is simply to have a
paid app or game this generally appears
like it's going to be like a minimum
amount of revenue that you'll obtain but
the outcome isn't always as clear when
you're deciding to do a paid app or paid
game make sure that the quality is
extremely high because people are gonna
expect this for this type of an app if
you're just testing out your MVP the
Minimum Viable Product and you don't
necessarily know where it lies on the
quality spectrum then you might want to
choose a different monetization method
with choosing a paid method so this is
outright paid it's best to look at all
of the different types of similarly paid
apps or games to determine the best
pricing strategy this might vary from
country to country or from you know time
of year for instance if you want to get
a lot of users very quickly and you're
not too worried about the return during
the holidays you might want a lower
pricepoint and if it's during the summer
and you don't really you don't see it
like a huge rush maybe it's a better
idea to price it a bit more of course
having a paid app or game doesn't mean
that you can't also have IPs or ads but
you have to be extremely careful not to
overdo it on those types of things
because there can be pushback from your
users or players there is no best choice
between interstitials that deliver CPC
or CPI it really depends on what's
converting the best in the end